my name is peter bartlett i'm the
associate director here um very happy to
have you
here for the first workshop in the
causality program
uh the workshop on learning and
interventions
um
first of all a big thank you to the
organizers for for this workshop uh
caroline uhler and bin new thanks very
much for all your work
so it's going to be a very exciting week
we're very uh happy to have the lineup
that we have
um
uh enthusiastic to see uh all the work
that's going on in the in the causality
program this semester it's a it's a big
and energetic program brought
more than 80 people to uh to berkeley
i'm going to hand over to
bin and
caroline in just just a moment i want to
say a few words about logistics for
for the week
so we need to keep masks on indoors
as you all know
also food and drink
we'll leave it outside
that's going to be during the breaks
you're on your own at lunch please don't
bring
drinks or food into the into the
auditorium
um
we do at lunch time you can you can
leave things in lockers on the far side
of the building there are lockers with
pin codes there
[Music]
also we have everything being streamed
uh
over zoom and over youtube and uh omid
fire our videographer here is going to
be helping speakers
hook up and microphones and so on
uh helping them with microphones and
hooking up computers
um
okay so uh and enjoy the week i'll head
over to
uh
let's do it
welcome to the workshop we're very
excited to have really a great program
covering
learning from interventions from theory
to practice and this morning i guess
caroline will be cheering and we're
going to keep
talks to 30 minutes so um
and then we have a panel
and then you see how caroline will
moderate the panel and we just invite
everyone to join and the speakers ask
each other questions
i'm very excited to meet many of you who
haven't met and see old friends
thank you ben yeah welcome also from my
end i'm really excited to see so many
people and others also joining online
we're really excited about this workshop
where we've tried to go very broad also
in terms of you know the different types
of applications
where interventional data is becoming
more abundant
all the way from education to
psychology to economics to biology etc
so hopefully we'll be actually spanning
the whole
a lot of the different applications and
in addition of course also having um
talks by researchers who have worked a
lot on on the foundations of how to
actually model and and and take into
account interventional data together
with observational data in order to get
at causality and so that's how we're
going to start the morning um so our
first speaker is going to be frederick
aberhart um who's a professor and
philosophy um at caltech and uh he has a
really exciting title up uh that i'm
really excited to hear and then
afterwards we'll have three more talks
so one more before the break all of them
will be online
and how we want to do this has been just
said is we'll have 30 minutes talks and
we'll keep i mean of course questions
that are of clarifying nature please go
ahead but all of the bigger questions
let's keep them for the panel discussion
which we have after every block so after
the morning block we'll have today a
panel discussion from 12 to 12 30 then
again in the afternoon we'll have a
panel discussion at the end where
hopefully we'll have a lot of discussion
so that we can find a bit more unifying
themes across the different talks and
have questions that relate to maybe
different talks or also single talks but
just so that there is a bit more of a
discussion across the different themes
so with that let's get started so
frederick um
please and thank you and
do i need to turn this off or
thank you for having me can you hear me
okay okay thank you um thanks for coming
uh uh i don't know what you're in for on
a
your gray valentine's day starting it
with me so uh i'm sorry about that um
okay uh the title is uh a twist on uh a
paper by eric hole which i'm going to be
discussing in some detail um and uh
look at it in
uh
at some of the parts where i don't think
it quite works out so here we go i'm
interested in causal macro variables so
in particular in high level abstractions
that we think we can construct of
low-level systems so for example we
often think of el nino as a causal level
as a
climate macro phenomenon we talk about
it as
affecting the the rainfall in california
as
affecting the droughts in australia and
southeast asia and it's a climate
phenomenon that is described largely in
terms of this tongue of hot water that
extends from the west coast of the
americas all the way across the pacific
and it's supposed to have an effect
different from the opposite la nina
which is this cold which is this tongue
of cold water extending from the west
coast of the americas into
the pacific and the thought is that we
can talk about el nino and la mena as
causes or effects of even the world
economy in that case as causes uh at
such a high level even though we think
they are constituted or uh supervene on
the low level phenomena of what's going
on in the equatorial pacific so my
question in general is not about el nino
or la nina specifically but under what
circumstances are we licensed and what
is needed to be able to talk about
causal relations at such a high abstract
level
so in particular if we look at wind maps
over the equatorial pacific and sea
surface temperature maps uh in the same
region then i want to know under what
circumstances is something like the
high-level abstract causal relation that
i've drawn there licensed namely that
something like westerly equatorial winds
are the cause of el nino and that
subsequently el the phenomenon of el
nino is a cause of rainfall and
subsequently economic impacts in the us
or in
southeast asia
of course this sort of multi-level
description of causal relations is not
restricted somehow to climate science we
find it as an old problem in mental
causation and philosophy where we're
interested in
how mental states how our thoughts
beliefs desires relate to the underlying
brain states
i think many of us believe that mental
states are constituted by the brain
states
that instantiate them and that mental
states might be able to cause each other
so my belief in something might cause me
to develop an intention to do something
else and ultimately lead to behavior and
that i'm licensed to talk in that way
even though what all that belief and
desire and intention and thought is
actually instantiated in is at a low
level in the in terms of a particular
brainstem so the question is why and
under what circumstances can we abstract
to such a psychological level
independent of the neuroscience that
underlies it
okay so in all these cases the idea is
that there is a causal relation that we
want to describe that is distinct from
the constitutive relation the brain
doesn't cause the mental state the
mental state is constituted by a
particular brain state but maybe we want
to say that the brain state can cause
subsequent brain states but at the same
time that we can talk at the higher
vertical level uh i will take keep this
distinction throughout the talk that the
constitutive relations are on the
vertical axis
that the mental state can still be said
to cause a subsequent mental state so
i'm interested in theories that build
this sort that take into account this
sort of multi-level causal analysis and
that look at what sort of criteria are
necessary to talk at an abstract level
about a very fine-grained
low-level system
okay so to get started a little bit more
formally the idea is we have some high
dimensional low level states i and j
that influence each other we can
intervene on them and what we want to
construct is some lower dimensional
abstraction in terms of c and e where we
still want to be able to talk causally
about that abstraction in the sense and
by talking causally about that
abstraction what i mean is that we can
make sense of say i'm intervening on c
and i can talk about the effect of an
intervention on c
while i full well acknowledge that c is
instantiated or constituted by the
underlying i and e is constituted by the
underlying j okay so in particular the
the functions that are vertical are not
causal ones whereas the functions that
are horizontal are causal relations
so if you look around for theories like
this then uh one of the theories that
you'll come across is uh one in a paper
developed by eric cole which is uh the
title is there when the map is better
than the territory in which my title for
this talk derives from
where he is one of the few people who
gives a very precise account of how to
piece together a low-level micro-level
system of interactions for which we then
can describe in very precise terms and
the circumstances under which the
abstraction to a
macro level is permitted so i want to
talk i want to explain what this theory
is and then i want to take a look at how
exactly it works or where it perhaps
doesn't work okay so he starts with a
finite speed speed it's a large finite
steep space at the micro level and it
turns out he has the causal relations
he's looking at one system over time
well you can think of it as over time
that he has as for the i and j the same
finite state speech we can argue about
that later whether that was a good idea
or not that that's the setup that he has
and then he describes the system's
causal relations at the micro level in
terms of the standard transition
probability matrix
you can think of this matrix as just
describing the probability of each state
j coming about given the particular
state i
since we're not talking about
confounding here at all um
you can also think of these
probabilities as just the interventional
probabilities if you manipulate i to a
particular micro level value what is the
probability that you get a specific
value of j
there is no so there are various ways of
interpreting this sort of system you can
think of it as looking at the system at
two different time points so i is the
system at time point one and j is the
system at time point two you but you
needn't think of it as a time series in
particular there's no commitment to this
time series
uh
equilibrating or being stationary or
anything like that um but you can also
just think of this a transition
probability matrix as the input output
relation of the system okay so
there are various ways of interpreting
it so of course any sort of course mean
of the state space of i and subsequently
of j
is a sort of abstraction of this model
but in order to say that we actually
have a macro level causal model i don't
think any sort of abstraction counts and
eric hull in his account says that what
really matters to having an appropriate
abstraction is that we maximize
effective information that is he says we
have a fine-grained micro level system
and we can describe that at the course
level by maximizing effective
information okay so the obvious question
is what is effective information
information effective information is
described in somewhat peculiar terms
it's not not uh
specific to whole it was developed by
others before
where the thought is that you have an
input intervention distribution which is
the maximum entropy distribution on the
cause so you intervene on the cause with
a maximum entropy distribution which in
this case given this sort of simplistic
system is just of course a uniform
distribution over the states and the
effect distribution is just the uh
distribution over the effect namely j in
this case that results from this maximum
entropy distribution over the course
right so the the distribution is given
by the transition probability matrix and
you just take the averages over the
transition probability matrix
nothing particularly exciting happening
here yet
so what effective information is
supposed to look at is it's supposed to
uh give you a sense of how much control
the cause has over the effect and so the
crucial part in
establishing effective information is to
look at how much does a speci the
distribution resulting from a specific
intervention when i set the micro level
i to little i how much does that diverge
from the general average effect
distribution when i put in a maximum
entropy distribution into the cause okay
how do we measure distances between
distributions well one way is to do it
with the kl divergence and that's
exactly what effective information does
so it's an average over the kl
divergences that we have between the
individual uh intervention on one
particular state and the average
intervention that we get when we take
the maximum entropy over
these states so if you look now at
effective information being defined in
this way then obviously you will
recognize the information theoretic
quantities that are there namely it's
just here the mutual information between
the cause and the effect when you put in
a maximum entropy distribution in the
cause and when you look at what the
effect is that results so the thought is
that effective information gives us a
notion of the type of causal control
that we have from the cause to the
effect
and it connects these sorts of causal
this causal control to information
theoretical notions namely that of
mutual information
okay that's all very nice um i think
there are a couple of other reasons why
why there is this focus on effective
information it's supposed to uh provide
a sort of directed notion of information
um since it's defined in terms of the
interventional distribution on on the
cause and it's also as i suggested with
the connection between causal control
and
mutual information
uh it's supposed to develop this sort of
bridge between causal notions and
informatic notions
why does why does it use the maximum
entropy distribution as the input
cause why does it use the maximum
entropy distribution over the cause as
the input well because i think there's
not much discussion and how the
motivation is that you want to explore
the full state space of the cause to get
a sense of what you can really do with
this sort of cause rather than focusing
merely on specific states that uh might
occur naturally in nature you would only
see a subset of possibly what you could
be doing with the
clarification does this definition
at all
so no
the maximum entropy distribution doesn't
maximize this quantity
so
this is just purely defined in terms of
i put in the maximum entropy
distribution and look what the effect
distribution is and that's i measure the
mutual information between the two
it doesn't
so there might well be a different
distribution over the cause that would
be uh that would result in higher mutual
information so if you're asking if it
maximizes mutual information that's not
the case or not necessarily the case
let's put it up
okay uh grit
these are questions that indicate that
you're exactly where i want you to be in
terms of the thinking great so what's
the thought then the thought is then as
you might expect it given the last
question is that look we have causal
emergence when we maximize effective
information that is we want to look at
the system at the micro level and then
say look what sort of effective
information is there between cause and
effect and can we maximize that in
effective information well can we
maximize that when we change the state
space of let me see whether this works
this will probably not be visible on
zoom but but you can see it so if you
change the state space of uh the input i
of the cause i can we maximize the
effective information between uh i and j
that's exactly the thought and so then
causal emergence occurs just in case you
can find a course mean of i
such that
you maximize effective information okay
well
that just the way i said it it's not
well defined yet because of course if i
want to compute effective information i
have to be able to
make sense of the intervention
distributions on the cause so
specifically what i haven't told you yet
is how do we make sense of an
intervention on the macro level c and by
setting it to c what does that to little
c what does that correspond to at the
micro level
okay
in general one can ask oneself is that
okay what when i set the temperature in
the room to 80 degrees fahrenheit what
does that correspond to at the micro
level
there are various ways that one can
think about it what whole does uh is to
say that i'm going to just take the
average of the interventions at the
micro level that correspond to 80
degrees fahrenheit okay so an
intervention on the macro level
is just the average of the interventions
that correspond to that value at the
macro level at the moment at the micro
level okay so i've written this somewhat
uh in a notation that is not actually uh
completely legitimate because i'm
writing that
the intervention on c is just the sum of
the interventions on on i that
correspond to that c of course the do
operator cannot be the uh the subject of
a sum just like that but you know i hope
intuitively at least that
if i wrote out the full formula it's
much more complicated to read because c
has to be a smaller space than i yes
that's the idea yeah so sorry that's
what i meant to say here when we
maximize effective information and we're
looking over the course means over the
speed space of course mean i mean
uh
yes the smaller speed so you merge
do you assume you know the size so you
also
do i assume i know the size of what
of c no that's what i'm searching so i'm
so the way to think of it is i'm
searching over all possible course names
so in the never mind how we do it
computationally more efficiently but so
conceptually the idea is that
i search over all possible course means
of i and look whether any of those uh
maximize effective information and if
any of the course means maximize
effective information so thereby i have
a variable c that has a smaller state
space than i in that case i have
causal emergence right so causal
emergence is not something that
necessarily occurs it's something that
only will occur if i can maximize
effective information by course yeah
okay great
okay uh um so the the overall picture
then is the following is that i'm i'm
going to have a micro level system i
have causal emergence just in case
i take when i have any sort of
coarsening of the micro level cause
i take a maximum entropy distribution
over that coarsening i take the mapping
from that intervention distribution on
the macro level to the micro level by
just taking averages over the
interventions on the micro level and if
this sort of courser description
maximizes effective information then i
have causal emergence okay that's the
thought so the first thing to notice
just as i said before
causal emergence doesn't occur for every
system some systems might be might
maximize effective information at the
finest granularity that's kind of that's
that's certainly possible
the other thing is to notice is that i'm
putting in a maximum entropy
distribution at the course level of
course that needed my map to a maximum
entropy distribution at the macro level
either
okay so if this is the setup uh then
notice that of course this goes back to
a question that was there earlier about
whether this maximizes mutual
information
it's uh it's close to maximizing mutual
information so notice if you maximize if
you if you think of maximizing mutual
information by looking over the possible
distributions over i
then
there is a close connection because
effective information is a sort of
mutual information that the maximization
here is over course means of i not over
distributions over the micro level i
right but if it were this sort of
maximization then we would of course be
talking about channel capacity right so
no surprise then that eric hole calls
this sort of notion the causal capacity
but this sort of approximate sign is of
the formal nature of hand waving at best
there's no sort of proof that says that
this approximation is tight or in any
sort of form
necessarily close so notice in
particular that the maximization of
effective information
is restricted namely you only look at a
subset of possible intervention
distributions namely those that are
maximum entropy at the course level
whereas if you maximize if you if you're
looking for channel capacity then you
maximize over all possible distributions
of the sender in this case on the other
side
identifical requires that there are
identical state spaces for i and j for
the input and output and of course if we
look at the channel capacity between
sender and receiver there is no such
requirement that we change the state
space of the receiver right we're just
searching over different distributions
over the sender right so that's why i'm
saying that while while eric cole gives
a whole bunch of examples where indeed
channel sorry causal capacity
approximates channel capacity this sort
of approximation is rather loose
okay
so just to give you an example of what
this sort of
technique gives you
here's an example of a very simple uh
transition probability matrix between
eight states in uh cause and it's in the
effect and of course if you look at this
then you will see the first seven states
are doing the same thing
have the same effect and so
unsurprisingly if you maximize
effective information then you end up
with c having just two states and e
having two states and the state
transition matrix that is just like this
um
uh where you collapse the first seven
steps none of this should be
particularly surprising that's what we
would expect that's that that an
abstraction of this sort of system
should uh just collapse the first seven
states because what's the point in
distinguishing the first seven states
they're doing the same thing okay
the more interesting case i think is
something like this that now it's not
going to be obvious to you i think
is that in fact if you maximize
effective information here then indeed
you end up with the same
transition probability matrix at the
abstract level at the core screening
system
and now notice that of course there are
a whole bunch of very different states
being collapsed together again the first
seven states are being collapsed
together but notice that state one and
state four have very different effects
for example on states uh what's that six
and seven so in particular state one
doesn't put any weight on state six and
seven where our state four puts about
almost half its weight on state six and
seven yet these two states are going to
be collapsed into one at the same macro
state okay question sorry
basic question so what prevents just a
trivial coarsening where
i mean ah because that would not
maximize effective information
effective information would go to zero
if you're just forcing everything
together no no i mean keep everything
separate
in this case
because it doesn't uh because if you do
then effective information is higher
which i think
might give you some sense that of course
effective information is maximized with
the with the transition probability
matrix like this right which is diagonal
with ones
right and uh so if you kept it like this
the affected information is just much
lower that's the reason
i i didn't i should have perhaps
included the numbers but yeah so can we
think of the the coursing ci is just the
partitions of i just look at that yeah
that's exactly what it was getting that
was just about the finite state that's
exactly what it is yeah i should have
sorry i meant to be explicit about that
okay
so so what bothers me about this sort of
thing so state one and state four
collapse into the same state macro state
but uh they seem to me at least to have
quite different causal effects so my
example for this sort of thing comes
from uh a paper by peter spurs and
richard shyness on
ambiguous manipulations and the thought
is that look if i have total cholesterol
as a macro variable and that is a cause
of heart disease but total cholesterol
is actually constituted by
happy lipids and lousy lipids yes uh and
happy lipids have a positive effect on
heart disease and lousy lipids have a
negative effect on heart disease
excuse my my medicine by to all the
medical professionals in here so this
has nothing to do with real medicine so
then
what i would say about this is that look
if you intervene now on total
cholesterol the effect of total
cholesterol is ambiguous because it
depends on the mixture of hdl versus ldl
on what the effect on heart disease is
of course i can fix the effect on heart
disease by fixing the distribution of
hdl versus ldl by say a maximum entropy
distribution i could do that
but that just means that i'm arbitrarily
fixing what my macro level description
is by the the the intervention
distribution that i'm putting in on the
course so i think these sorts of things
where you collapse two different sorts
of causes that have very different
effects into one variable and thereby
create these sorts of ambiguous
manipulations is something that you
don't want to have in your construction
or you want to very be very careful
about in your construction of macro
variables so then the obvious sorry
yet sorry i missed this this is probably
you said it but how is the state's size
of the states-based cfi determined i
mean how many
uh elements in the course think
so you go through
of the c okay so you start with a finite
state space in i and you search over all
possible course means of
i and so the state space in c will
obviously be finite but at most as large
as i and then you look for
that state space that maximizes
effective information and that fixes the
the size of the state's vision c
okay so it is over it's not that that's
predetermined so you could have any side
state space you want
well
yeah okay got it thank you sorry sure um
sorry i should have been clear about
that as well so um so obviously for me
the question is like okay we've got this
difference here but how bad could this
difference be right how far apart can i
push states
such that they still get collapsed into
the same macro state okay so here's a
simple example
that we looked for so notice that states
one and two have quite different causal
effects i would suggest
but they still get collapsed into the
same state space now you might say okay
look they are quite different but are
they really that different both of them
are more different to the third state
that has been kept separate right but
notice if i had changed 0.7 to 0.8 here
then
we wouldn't be collapsing these two
anymore so if you're thinking that look
this this third state is really
different from the first two um then i'm
with you i can see that you might want
to collapse under that sort of
qualitative notion the first two states
but wouldn't you also have that view
then if i changed the first point seven
to point eight it seems like that's not
the difference that if i change the
first point seven to point eight i
wouldn't collapse i would stay at this
uh micro level uh uh um partition so
obviously if i ask about how far can i
push the effect of different states
apart then that depends on the distance
metric that i'm using to separate how
different two the effects of two states
are in this case i just maximize the
absolute value between
uh
these these probabilities here in the uh
transition probability matrix but we
also looked at a whole pile of other
measures in all cases the upshot is
that the boundary where suddenly the
effect of information collapses the two
states seems firstly to occur at a point
when these states are extremely
different already
but then also
just slightly more different and you
don't collapse it doesn't seem like that
lines up with what we intuitively might
think would be a point where we say that
we should be collapsing uh but sorry
yeah so just a question about the
calculation so the way you write it
seems like the
thing you're maximizing too is like on
the three by three kind of
so
yeah so it's it's a it's a little bit
tricky to write this because we're we're
going to take apart a course mean of i
and then we look at the effective
information from that coursing so i
could write c of i here if you if that
would help the problem is if i write
that then i would have to write c of i
here as well and then my notation
gets really messy because the state
space between i and j has to be the same
right so you're right is that
to be completely precise i should have
written the course and version of i here
and the course inversion of j here and
that's what we're looking for the
effective information yeah okay i was
debating about changing that notation
but thought this would be simpler
obviously that didn't work so sorry
about that
um okay so that was my first point so my
first concern is that we we have very
separate causal effects in this sort of
system that are collapsed at the point
that seems absolutely arbitrary
um okay i want to talk about a different
uh thing very quickly do i still have a
few minutes
give me a few extra please um so uh um
normally when we talk about causal
models we're perfectly happy to think
about marginalization and we look at
okay if we have a micro level causal
model like this we're not troubled by
saying that look this long arrow that i
drew there actually is secretly
representing that there are other
mediators that are along the way okay
so there could have been an i prime
there somewhere along the way we just
didn't represent it right so we
marginalized it up so maybe then you
should think that look we should also be
able to think of
the system that way at the macro level
as well that the arrows that we draw at
the macro level also might contain
mediators
but if that's your view i think that's
the view you ought to have um then um
and that's i think actually the view
that most of us have implicitly who work
with causal models anyway then i think
abstraction and marginalization should
commute that is to say if i first were
to marginalize out the middle variable
here and then abstract just the relation
between i and j
then i should get the same thing as if i
abstract the relationship between i and
i prime and the relationship between i
prime and j and then when i've got my
system up here i marginalize out c prime
okay so to me it should it seems like
marginalization and abstraction should
commute because we we're implicitly
marginalizing all the time when we draw
our causal models
well as you might expect this is not
going to work in this sort of case and
the reason is of course trivial but i
just want to point it out so we just go
through an example here we've got
transition probability matrices i'm
going to abstract the individual
relations i to i prime first i get this
this one and since the transition
probability matrix is exactly the same i
do i get the same abstract relationship
here if i now marginalize that's the uh
transition probability matrix that i end
up with i have two states at the macro
level okay now we do it the other way
around i first marginalize the bottom
one which means i just take the square
of the transition probability matrix
that's this if i mark if i try to
maximize effective information now turns
out it's already maximized at the micro
level okay
so there is no effective information is
already
maximized there is no further
abstraction that happens so obviously
these two are not the same so
marginalization and abstraction don't
commute i think that's a problem i think
that really undermines your kind of
model because it suggests that the kind
of representation that you or the kind
of abstraction that you're getting is
extraordinarily sensitive in how you
pick your variables along the way
obviously the problem the source of the
problem here is that for the
marginalized sorry for the abstraction
you're always introducing these sorts of
maximum entropy distributions into the
system so when i when i construct the
abstraction of the i prime to j relation
i'm putting in a maximum entropy
distribution here on the i prime but of
course that maximum entropy distribution
will not look like the effect that i'm
getting from the first uh variable so
when i marginalize i'm getting something
very different from um
from the
then when i abstract first it's not it's
this is this is really a trivial point
once you see how the model is working
but it really i think screws up this
sort of setup so last two slides and
i'm there with you hang on so
a couple of general points i think it is
worth distinguishing between macro level
causes or causal representations as it's
sometimes discussed now as well and
mixtures of causal effects i think there
are two different things they uh there
there are such things where we have
mixtures of effects and there are things
where we want to
talk about the macro level
representation as causal in its own
right okay so when i take off my sweater
because the temperature is at 80 degrees
fahrenheit that's a different story than
some sort of mixture of
the causal effects of the micro level
representation it's unsensitive to the
macro level cause okay the second point
is what got screwed up i think in holds
account is that
um there was an introduction of of these
intervention probabilities namely the
maximum entropy distribution and instead
i think when we talk about macro level
causes what we should be sensitive to is
just the conditional probability
distribution or the interventional uh uh
conditional probability distribution of
the effect given an intervention on the
cause this sort of conditional is the
relevant thing to look at when we look
at abstractions we should not worry
about what the intervention distribution
is over the cause and i think that's
where things go wrong in several
accounts actually
but if if you do that then you'd also
don't run into this problem with abs the
commutation of abstraction and
marginalization i've not discussed this
here but i'm happy to talk about it
i think there's a very crucial
difference between asking what the macro
level causes and what the macro level
effect is we need to distinguish those
two questions
and address them separately and this
sort of account that i just presented by
fixing the state space of the effect to
be the same as the cause
arbitrarily picks a coarsening of the
effect that i don't think has any
independent justification that should
not be the way to go specifically about
holds account i think the relation
between information theory and uh
causality via this notion of effective
information is tenuous or suggestive at
best
um i i don't think it is as close as
he's suggesting i think that would be it
would be nice to have that sort of
connection to information theory but
this is not it
channel capacity in the information
theoretic sense is a normative concept
that means whether or not the channel
capacity is exhausted is an empirical
question whether your sender is actually
any good at sending their messages is an
empirical question so similarly the
causal emergence here that
is defined by eric holds account is a
notion of possible emergence not of
actual emergence it may not ever be
exhibited by the system in question
and finally
effective information when you maximize
it
it is always unique but it is not clear
that the implied partition over the the
the value of effective information is
always unique when you maximize it but
it's not clear that the partition that
maximizes effective unif
information is unique so there could be
two different partitions that both
maximize effective information but they
then would be very different causal
abstractions that would be somewhat
peculiar now i think this cuts both ways
either
you want a unique abstract model and you
think there is a unique way of
abstractly describing a system then this
is not going to work or you don't want
it because you think there can be causal
abstractions at multiple levels right
there's quantum physics there's physics
there's biology there's economics right
um and so then you might want causal
stories at each of these levels but then
this sort of maximization of effective
unit information is not going to give
you those different types of uh um
uh uni
those different levels that's it
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
definitely got some slack it's the as
the main organizer of this whole program
and all the work you've done for us
all right so uh we're moving on to the
next talk which will be given virtually
i'm looking for some guidance on what i
have to do